[Music]
This kid is a bit of a bully. What's the
point? This isn't just a kid's story.
[Music] The fact that he
talked about it means he's a legitimate person with a long lifespan. Maybe it makes sense, Mr.
Ege, too. It's forced.  If someone
calls me and directs me with unspoken murderous intent, I won't be
able to keep quiet, but my fighting ability hurts, and no matter how strong my scales are, if I get hit by strong water magic, they'll turn into scales.I wonder what kind of touch they'll make.Who wants to
touch me?
I want to pet you with my fingers. I'm not afraid of you. I'm a
strange child. The
dragon is preparing to attack.
[Music] It
feels good until I have to wait.
[Music]